[Music]
across the world's religions we have
gods that are
depicted as having all the omnis you
know
omnipotent omniscience ultimate
you know never dies not of bodily form
but has these
really uncanny interests
in very human-like concerns like
territory like
sex like like giving up food resources
you know a lot of cultures give up
give up food for their dominant their
dominant male gods
why would that be why why would a god
require these things who doesn't need
these things
so the answer is this god is based on on
us
and it's not until we really understand
some of our evolved psychology
especially our reproductive psychology
that we can begin to
to really um you know delineate what
what drives people to commit atrocities
or
engage in jihad or crusades or steer
airplanes into buildings based on their
religion
or oppress women things like that okay
so it sounds to me like
there are some qualities that gods have
that humans share
and it sounds to me like there's a leap
that's made which is like hey first of
all why is it that gods have these
qualities when they seemingly don't
need them and then your answer is
because
they're human constructions and i'm
wondering
that to me seems like a leap i mean it's
not a big leap
but it but it is a leap because we don't
know what the god realm
what the spiritual realm what the
transcendent realm needs
so for example for example you mentioned
jealousy
like why would god be jealous well the
answer is the answer could simply be i
don't know or we don't know
or people don't know because it's a
realm that we don't have access to
what's what's wrong with simply saying
that
we don't know why is the the the leap
made from
human motivations and intentions to
to okay therefore the god must be a
human construction
i i don't think it's ever uh a good idea
just to say we don't know and
and and leave it like that or it's or
it's cannot be explained or it's just
mysterious i think we have to seek
answers to the unknown and the more we
do that
the better you know life gets for
everybody you know the human experience
progresses along um so
so you know to understand
the god of the abrahamic face for
example i think i think some basic
tenets of
of our reproductive psychology is
probably in order so that
that viewers will understand where this
is all coming from and and one
idea um there's there's a huge body of
research that
looks at our mating strategies and a lot
of it has been
happening for decades and much of it
coming from david buss's lab out of ut
austin
which in a way kind of um
operationalizes and studies something
that we
we all kind of know and one is that that
you know men and women engage in
different reproductive strategies
men tend to prefer numbers men engage in
a number strategy
across the world men tend to prefer more
sexual partners as compared to women
women tend to be far choosier and
you know the main reason for that is
men's um
evolutionary fitness is directly
proportional
to number of copulations frankly a man
can reproduce
theoretically with every sexual
encounter and that's not true for women
women tend to be far choosier
um but what men and women bring to their
to
to the reproductive exchange is is very
different
men produce sperm well into their
geriatric years by the millions
women's reproductive output is very very
limited
right it's a scarce resource limited to
the span between
adolescents and menopause limited by
things like um
pregnancy and by polygyny where powerful
men
hoard women and reduce their
availability in in the mating pool
so roughly worldwide the ratio
of of men to women is roughly and there
are some differences roughly one to one
right but the operational sex ratio the
number of available men
to available women is far-skewed towards
men there's a lot more sexually
available reproductively available men
so just like in economics when
when you have resources that are scarce
and high demand
you have competition and and very often
that competition has been
violent you know uh in the natural world
and we can see this in other primates i
mean male baboons will
chase each other on the savannas and and
attack each other with these
you know five-inch long canines
all kinds of male primates compete for
for sexual access
chimpanzees this is really interesting
if you've ever get to watch one of these
documentaries it's fascinating where you
show chimpanzees preparing for war
normally
boisterous loud hooting panting
grab-assing chimpanzees go totally quiet
and they form these all-male squads
silently and in single file patrol the
edges of their territory it looks like
men
patrolling in the jungles of vietnam it
just it's it's
eerie how familiar that is so
if they find a smaller troop or a lone
male they attack them
savagely and and you know if numbers are
superior often they kill
the males so when enough of these raids
are conducted
you they can eliminate all the males
from the rival troop
and move into that territory
fruit fruit trees game animals and
females they absorb the females in that
group
so that increases their reproductive
opportunity so
chimpanzees have a reproductive
incentive
to form male alliances and make
war men have this incentive too and men
have always done this through since we
were hunter-gatherers you know
conducting raids on the outside tribes
stealing their women in war wartime rape
is incredibly con
in fact you know biblical war also has
these narratives played out
so for example you know in in the bible
uh to reportedly god commands moses to
go to the rival tribe
kill all the boys kill all the men kill
all the women who've slept with the man
and save for yourself
all the girls who who are pure so to
speak
so engaging in this very visceral form
of male-made competition that's not just
the story of mo
it goes throughout the whole bible
especially the old testament
you